endgame okay people endgame was the
biggest movie of all time all the Marvel
movies the Marvel movie and I I think
the population of Earth yeah that movie
I think six times yeah okay I did not
see it
yeah that's okay Oh let's get oh wow I'm
proud of that but no one cares yeah with
this audience like what's wrong with him
yeah yeah yeah wouldn't go not gonna do
it so there's a lot of people that
thought that you played the younger
Stanley they were convinced that it was
you and it became a thing online let's
put it up there and it does sort of look
I mean it really does kind of look like
you and I was convinced that you did it
is it is there any chance that you're
not telling people when it really was
you know it's not me it looks like my
character on glow actually but there is
some momentum around trying to get me to
play Stanley but that was definitely not
me I I was not in a Marvel movie right I
have some I've some issues with you
don't like comic book movies I some
issues with them and no I generally
don't like them because I you know I
don't want to be bullied into seeing
those look Conan I'm a grown-up I'm not
seven and I think those movies are
firfer you know grown male nerd childs
and and and and oh really
oh yeah why take the hit you guys are in
charge of culture now I got it I got to
go travel 15 20 minutes to a smaller
movie theater to see a grown-up movie
with other grownups where we can all sit
together and not understand the ending
you know
[Laughter]
yeah yeah when you walked out you're
like I don't know that the guy died it's
not it's not clear now
that's the kind of movie I enjoy I'm not
gonna be bullied by grown nerd men so no
did you were you backstage saying I'm
gonna alienate everybody it's the thing
we've been doing since 1993 there's no
one better than us you know look I just
don't go see him I'm not interested
right that's all right maybe I overdid
it a little
[Laughter]